Jane the Virgin might sound like a
mundane name but the show is anything
but predictable fans up and kept on
their toes from the get-go but nothing
compares to what was revealed during the
season 4 finale Jane the virgin has so
many plot twists it's hard to keep track
of who's who and who's dating who keep
watching as we reveal the series biggest
plot twist I'm sorry I lied before
Jane's pregnant Jane Villanueva is a
kind and passionate woman who was
determined to make her abuela proud and
remain a virgin until her wedding night
she had her life all planned out
marriage success buying her first house
and having children when she was good
and ready well life had a different
story in mind for the aspiring novelist
Jane's unexpected pregnancy was the
series first plot twist this huge
curveball is the basis of the entire
show but wait how does a virgin get
pregnant well to make a long story short
the events were due to a case of medical
and professionalism despite the fact
that Jane was going to her gyno for a
standard examination her doctor was
distraught and therefore inseminated her
with Rafael's specimen never in a
million years would Jane believe that
motherhood was on the horizon still she
made her choice and decided on raising
the baby with or without Rafael or her
fiance Michael stamp of approval Jane's
father
Jane grew up under the premise that
family and honesty were two of the most
important things in the world however
she would later find out that everything
she knew was alive Jane's mother gave
birth to Jane when she was only 16 years
old she wanted to keep her baby so she
never told her mother who Jane's father
really was as a result she had to keep
Jane's father's identity a secret
coincidentally Jane's father Roja Leo
was the star of Jane's favorite
telenovela
so despite not knowing him she'd managed
to grow up alongside him via the TV set
when Jane was 23 years old she found out
that her mother had lied to her for her
entire life and their relationship took
a major hit just when we thought that
Jane had her plateful with an unplanned
pregnancy a new and very dramatic
parental figure came into her life I'm
your father
Petra and Roman Petra and Romans
relationship might not seem like the
biggest plot twist but it's crucial to
the story nonetheless at first we feel
bad for Petra after all a random woman
was just inseminated with her rightful
child
but our sympathy soon runs dry when we
find out that Petra is having an affair
with her husband's best friend Roman
zazo this moment sets a string of future
events into motion not only does this
affair lead to Petra and Rafael's
falling out but it also makes room for a
romance twins big reveal Romans sudden
demise is a big turning point in season
one if it's a hotel under fire and adds
stress to an already stressful situation
but nothing compares to when we find out
that Roman faked his own death by
throwing his twin brother Aaron off the
balcony later on in the series Roman
poses as Aaron and kidnaps Petra after
causing a mess of things if we didn't
know any better we'd say Petra has
terrible taste in men well with the
exception of Raphael of course Petra
isn't who she says she is Petra Solano
has always been ahead of the game she's
sneaky conniving and determined to win
any fight that comes her way
but the ice queen has a secret that
could very well ruin her life and land
her in jail she's not who she says she
is in fact Petra's real name is Natalia
and she's not an American citizen
Natalia was born in the Czech Republic
but fled her country in 2009 to get away
from her ex-boyfriend Milo's once in
America Natalia changed her name to
Petra and set her sights on marrying a
rich bachelor she was engaged to Lachlan
more before dumping him and marrying
Rafael Solano after Rafael files for
divorce
Petra goes to great lengths to trap him
in their marriage she frames him for
domestic abuse gets him demoted
sabotages his reputation and tries to
get legal rights over Rafael and Janes
baby
this causes Rafael to dig into Petra's
past for blackmail
we hired a private investigator only to
find out that she's an illegal immigrant
now that was a major curveball catcher
gets pregnant after finding out who his
wife really is Rafael is more than
willing to fast-track his divorce but
Petra isn't about to give up so easily
so when Luisa informs her that the lab
found an extra vial of Rafael's frozen
specimen she collects it and self
inseminates herself with it we couldn't
leave her eyes Petra would stop at
nothing to keep Rafael in her back
pocket despite the low chances of
carrying a child to term Petra got
pregnant and soon found out that she was
having twins so not only was Rafael
having an unplanned baby with Jane but
he was now expecting twin girls with
Petra
this was a plot twist Raphael never saw
coming especially since he hadn't been
romantically involved with Petra Jane at
the time of conception Petra has a twin
one of the biggest plot twist is
revealed when Petra comes face to face
with her twin sister and Eska at first
fans were led to believe that Petra was
wearing a brown wig and acting shady
however it was soon revealed that this
person wasn't Petra it was her long-lost
twin and Eska grew up in an orphanage in
Czech Republic where she grew to be shy
and fearful Petra token Eska in gave her
a job at the Marbella and gave her the
benefit of the doubt
however we later find out that anezka is
conspiring with Magda in an attempt to
steal Rafael's fortune and leave the
country but the most shocking thing of
all is when we discover that Anushka has
stolen her sisters identity by putting
her in a poison induced coma and as
cause poor decision-making skills led to
her demise later on in the series all in
all Anastas mere existence and what it
entailed led to some of the biggest plot
twists the series had to offer Luisa and
roses secret relationship
you remember Luisa right Rafael's
tormented sister who accidentally
inseminated Jane with her brother's baby
well in her defense she had just found
out that her wife was having an affair
[Music]
so she had her reasons for being
distraught Louisa's character has been
full of surprises and her mental state
has been challenged throughout the
series however finding out that Luis and
her stepmother Rose were romantically
involved was a major shocker
turns out Luis and Rose met in a bar and
fell in love only to later find out that
Rose was engaged to Lewis's father
Emilio Solano
now that's super awkward anyway their
secret love affair has caused major
issues throughout the series and Rose
has yet to give up on courting Luisa
roses sin rostro at first we have no
reason to suspect Rose Solano of being
sin rostro in fact many of us believed
the notorious King Penn to be a man but
it was later revealed that Rose was sin
rostro when she murdered her husband
Emilio and reported him as missing so
not only was Rose running an illegal
plastic surgery operation at the
Marbella altering criminals faces and
lying about it but she was also slaying
anyone who got in her way who we once
thought to be a confused
love stricken attorney turned out to be
this series biggest villain Rose will
stop at nothing to be with Louisa she
even impersonated a woman named Eileen
to be by her side which led to Scott
Archuleta's unexpected demise Rose
kidnaps Mateo wants it's revealed that
roses sin rostro she flees the Marbella
and asks Louie said to run away with her
however their romantic getaway doesn't
pan out at first and Luisa gets her
hands on Rose's flash drive desperate to
retrieve it Rose keeps a low profile
until Jane goes into labor and after
Jane gives birth to Mateo Rose sends a
fake nurse to the hospital to kidnap the
newborn no problem I'll take him she's
willing to trade Louie says nephew for
the flash drive and she gets what she
wants
watching Mateo get kidnapped was
absolutely heartbreaking this scene was
a total GameChanger and it showed us how
far Rose was willing to go to come out
on top
Nadine is a double agent we don't know
about you but we were stunned when
Nadine was revealed to be working for
sin rostro from the start she was on
Michaels case when it came to being an
honest cop Nadine was Michael's partner
and he never would have suspected her of
colluding with the enemy so neither did
we instead of turning her in Michael
lets Nadine go and later pays the price
however getting into trouble with his
police chief was a small price to pay as
Nadine later jumps in front of a bullet
to save Michael's life giving her own up
in the process she made it clear that
she was only working for rose to protect
her family
but her betrayal was a shock nonetheless
Rafael was adopted Rafael Solano has
spent his entire life thinking that his
father didn't love him because he wasn't
good enough I need to stick around to
supervise things but he later found that
his father never loved him because he
doubted that Rafael was his true born
son this was reflected in his will which
clearly stated that only his biological
children could inherit his fortune
Rafael's mother Elena was believed to
have passed away when Rafael was only
four years old but we soon find out that
she's very much alive and posing as the
crime lord mutter to make matters worse
Rafael then finds out that he was
adopted as a baby and was actually born
in Italy it turns out his mother adopted
him after she lost her own child Elena
aka mutter is eventually assassinated by
Rose
Prison which was also a major plot twist
Magda can walk if you think Petra is a
bad person wait until you meet her
mother Magda this selfish and
manipulative woman will stop at nothing
to get what she wants and what she wants
is the good life Magda has been
controlling Petra since she was a kid
she convinced Petra that her
ex-boyfriend Milo's wanted to end her
life for years Petra believes that
Milla's threw acid on her causing her
mother to get projected onto the street
where she was hit by a car this however
turned out to be karma as Magda had been
concocting a string of lies to keep
Petra wrapped around her finger
Magda pretended to be paralyzed from the
waist down for years so we were super
surprised when Magda stood up from her
wheelchair to push abuela down the
stairs this life-threatening event was
only the beginning though because once
Petra found out that her mother was
faking her disability to manipulate her
things between them were forever changed
just when I think you can't sink any
lower mother Magda would eventually go
to prison for crimes but that never
stopped her from meddling in Petra's
life although Rose has proven to be the
series big bad Magda tends to give her a
run for her money
problem is Magda isn't too smart and her
plans usually fail RIT Michael although
many of us have been rooting for Jane
and Rafael since the very beginning we
can't deny that Michael's a stand-up guy
the Jane the Virgin narrator had once
told us that Michael would love Jane
until his dying breath but we never
expected his demise to happen so
suddenly and out of the blue after
marrying Jane Michael is shot by sin
rostro and barely escaped with his life
he's told to take it easy and that he
should pursue another career path
Michael recovers but suddenly passes
away after suffering an aortic
dissection
after taking the LSAT exam Michaels
demise was thought to be the biggest
curveball of the series but nothing
compared to what we found out at the end
of season 4 Michael is still alive
that's right guys Michael is still alive
problem is he doesn't remember anything
about his past life according to Michael
he spent the last three years working on
a farm trying to remember who he was
this revelation is the biggest plot
twist of all time we mean come on give
Jane a break she went from being a
pregnant virgin to a single mother to a
married woman and then a widow and now
Jane is on
and utterly confused so which plot twist
was your favorite do you think this
Jason guy is really Michael or is there
something else going on entirely let us
know in the comments section below
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you love Jane the
Virgin and don't forget to subscribe to
the things for more awesome videos we'll
see you next time
[Music]